les retrouvailles après huit ans de part
et d'autre du mur de berlin
plus qu'une ville en 1961 le mur de
berlin à séparer des proches du jour au
lendemain
5075 personnes ont réussi à rallier la
partie ouest entre 1961 et 1989
au début la fuite consiste à traverser
le no man's land exposés aux tirs des
soldats très risqué
[Musique]
certains ont creusé des tunnels 40 au
total pour 57 fugitif la liberté a
commencé ici dans la cave d'une ancienne
boulangerie de la bernauerstrasse plus
ingénieux encore des passages dans des
voitures même de toute petite taille à
chacun de ses retours de berlin est un
deuxième passager était du voyage
insoupçonnable dans une voiture de cette
taille
on
passé le mur aussi par la voie des airs
en 1979
un couple a réussi à construire un
ballon avec des chiffons une histoire
plus tard raconté par les gîtes et
étrangers plus adapté par hollywood
cette montgolfière s'était élevé de nuit
indétectable par les radars
nous avions emmené une bouteille de
champagne est-allemand pour fêter notre
réussite
nous l'avons vu tout de suite après
l'atterrissage un trafic s'est organisé
pour passer la frontière dite de la
liberté entre 20000 et 30000 francs la
traversée via des tunnels ou des camions
de déménagement conçu pour cacher des
personnes à la manoeuvre se sont souvent
d'anciens allemands de l'est comme ceux
propriétaires de cafés en 1978 je ne
fais pas évadés les gens pour de
l'argent dit il mais pour me venger des
tortures celui en rda
j'ai été emprisonné pendant plusieurs
années nuire aux communes y est ma seule
joie les rêves de liberté ne traverse
pas toujours le mur ils sont 80 18 à
avoir été rattrapés par la vigilance des
gardes des miradors des chiens des
balles 98 personnes ont perdu la vie
dans leur fuite vers l'ouest
[Musique]